big big weekend in the world of horse
racing justified became the second ever
undefeated Triple Crown winner now this
was a big deal huge victory huge victory
for the horse and it prompted this very
unusual tweet from Sheriff David a Clark
jr. a controversial right-wing figure
everything has to be politicized these
days he wrote Donald Trump should invite
justify to the White House lawn for
winning the Triple Crown justifies a
winner like Trump who could care less
about leftist identity politics
hashtag Magga well a lot of people were
making fun of sheriff Clark for this
tweet but then this this really
surprised me check it out this morning
justify the horse got on Twitter and
tweeted this I cannot in good conscience
visit the White House well we have a
sitting president who chooses to divide
rather than unite our nation also I love
oats pretty strong
pretty strong words from justified and
of course course Twitter then blew up
over this equine Patriot 1776 replied
how much did George Euros pay you to say
that respect our president or briskly
trot out of our country glue emoji glue
emoji glue emoji yeah
then mr. ed Nugent tweeted it's a good
thing horses are physically incapable of
vomiting because your liberal commie BS
makes me sick
hashtag drained the stable hashtag Apple
yeah
pony pony pony just tweeted this meme of
a horse Yellen damn Daniel yeah horse
lives matter' tweeted I wouldn't eat a
carrot out of Trump's hand even if he
presented it to me with a flat open palm
horseshoe emojis clapping Shetland
Shetland justice warrior tweeted this
gift with that feeling when you just
totally owned sheriff Clark
horse politics us said quick Gallup poll
was justifies tweet out of line yay 1%
nay 1% and nay 99% yeah a a user called
not a Russian bot horse tweeted hello
friend this is real horse to say Trump
is never won best president and pleased
to locking up crooked justify hashtag
makes sugar cubes great again hashtag
free nude pics XXI yeah it won't stop in
four wars wrote this very angry tweet
celebrity horses need to shut their
mouths and leave politics to cows sheep
and sand cats yeah
then whinny for me replied I stand with
justify and cat Burnett with this image
of a horse kneeling yeah
then Myron the horse tweeted I poop
standing up then Steve Benton replied to
this tweet me too so
horses just lost their mind Wow
you